[Music]
[Music]
and Lola and I had electrician from
Liverpool Football Club good and hassle
nutrition is the capital of the body for
every person it's really really
important to stay healthy to avoid
illness just to go on in your normal
life being energized and refuel to do
good performance rather my new role here
in the club I can care of all the
nutrition belongings of players the good
holistic nutrition some the right
fuelling and the right recovery and
being prepare for the next month we have
different columns of recovery so that
means sleeve the right nutrition the
right supplementation so we have tourism
affairs of our nutrition partner because
they are infamous for to prove so that
means they have a lot of experience
working with elite and the anti-doping
testing we were looking for somebody who
could adapt on our individual needs and
reacting on these things we want to
serve and provide for the players
the Maltese I called you what we have
from the professional footballers that
they are having high intensity training
and a lot of flash days it is sometimes
play three planes a week and sometimes
we have highly temperature training but
what we try to do is to react on the
intensity of the training or the economy
or somatic we kind of reduce it to some
one lane field we can not only reduce it
on carbohydrates or all your protein we
have a debate a very good holistic high
quality nutrition we have a close look
on the body composition we are in a
narrow exchange with all our colleagues
around over the medical department of
fitness department so with these
informations we try to organize the best
ultra sure for the players happening the
best recovery the separate grueling as
prevailing best hydration and this is
only possible because having a closer
look on all the information to get from
the players and having the right
products around so we've had happy that
we have a partner with FAS where we can
react on these individual needs of the
players
you
you